les plaques d'immatriculation laisse
croire qu'on est devant un hôpital
québécois mais en fait nous sommes à
l'hôpital de hawkesbury en ontario mon
médecin en ontario je prends pas de
médecins au québec parce qu'un impôt ça
explique pourquoi près de la moitié des
patients de cette urgence ontarienne
serait québécois c'est tout temps des
réponses qu'on au québec on n'a pas de
classe ça va être long
dans toutes les départements pareil et
il n'y a pas de service au québec
certains patients ontariens sont irrités
de l'omniprésence des québécois mais
leurs soins payés par le québec ont
permis de moderniser l'hôpital de
hawkesbury
dans la mrc d'argenteuil au sud des
laurentides huit à dix mille personnes
ont reçu des soins de santé en ontario
l'an passé y at il eu peur des gens
comme ellen et william vorax
ils ont un médecin de famille ontarien
parce que leurs médecins québécois est
parti à la retraite si on doit rentrer à
l'hôpital de rock ce pays en urgence en
fait on peut attendre quelques années
c'est pas comme ici dans la région ne
peux répéter passé 12 heures dans la
salle d'attenté
williams au rox a même subi un
remplacement de la hanche en ontario
toutes nos services médecins spécialisés
souvient de l'ontario c'est comme une
loterie pour être capable une fois par
année de rencontrer notre médecin
richard francoeur a aussi un médecin
ontarien depuis la retraite de son
médecin québécois et il obtient aussi
des services de médecine spécialisée en
ontario échographie radiographier des
choses comme ça
scanner risk and on va en ontario parce
que les rendez-vous sont beaucoup plus
rapides
entre 2017 et 2021 le nombre de
patientes d'argenteuil qui ont consulté
en obstétrique en ontario a augmenté de
55% en radiologie pour la même période
la hausse a été de 56 % vétusté encombré
l'hôpital de la chute est boudée au
profit des établissements ontariens
un phénomène qui touche aussi la région
frontalière de vaudreuil soulanges 30 à
40% de la population va chercher des
soins de santé en ontario notamment
l'hôpital dans l'hexagone y trouver un
médecin de famille y est une chasse au
trésor et l'accès à la médecine
spécialisée est difficile résultats de
2010 est à 2021 le nombre de patientes
québécoises qui ont obtenu des services
d'obstétrique en ontario a augmenté de
94% et en orthopédie la hausse a été de
69 %
la solution passe par la construction
d'un nouvel hôpital dans ses champs ou
pour l'instant rien n'avance on nous
parle à l'époque de 2016 dont les rendus
en 2022 on a toujours portes en
attendant le médecin québécois du préfet
de la mrc lui conseille simplement de
traverser la frontière et qui me
recommande lui même d'aller soit ou
privées ou de prendre rendez-vous un
cardiologue
vous avez votre réponse car c'est ton
propre médecin qui te suggère ici david
gêne-t-il et radio canada montréal